فضيحه فساد جديده تتكشف في صنعاء الواقعه
تحت سيطره ميليشيات الحوثيين المدعومه من
ايران عشره مليارات الريالات على شكل
حوالات ماليه لم يتم تسليمها لاصحابها
يعود بعضها لقبيل سنوات كما تشير وثائق
مسربه تضمنت كشوفات بالاسماء والمبالغ
وشركات الصرافه المتورطه حيث تشير
المعلومات ان الميليشيات الحوثيه تتسلم
تلك الاموال وتستخدمها في حروبها او في
شبكات الفساد التي يملكها كبار قاده
الميليشيات هل الحوالات عاده تكون عرضه
لاختلاسات لانه حتى من كبار موظفي الشبكات
او من بعض
الاشخاص اللي ممكن يعرفون هذه الحالات لم
تستلم وبالتالي يحاولوا يعني سرقتها او او
اختلاسها
فكان يجيب على هذه الشبكات ان تقوم هذه
الاجراءات مؤخرا لاثار الموضوع هو قيام
احد
المبرمجين
نشر حوالات احد الشبكات فيما يتعلق بالبنك
المركزي نحن الان حاليا نعمل على على
اطلاق الشبكه الموحده هذه الشبكه ان شاء
الله هذا الشهر
وتشير الوثائق المسربه الى تورط الكبريات
شركات الصرافه في اليمن والتي تعمل في
صنعاء تحت اشراف الحوثيين الذين انشؤوا ما
يسمونه بنكا مركزيا تابعا للميليشيات بعد
ان نقلت الحكومه الشرعيه البنك المركزي
للبلاد الى العاصمه المؤقته عدن ولا شك ان
المبالغ كبيره جدا التي علم انها نسيت او
تم تجميدها وهي تتجاوز المليارات وربما
يستفاد منها في اي خارج الاطار القانوني
ونحتاج الى ان تكون هناك رقابه دوليه في
طبيعه التحكم بهذه الاموال ومصادرها او
توجيهها توجيه خاطئ ضجه كبيره اثارتها
فضيحه الحوالات المحتجزه والتي تبلغ عشرات
المليارات من الريالات وتداول اليمنيون
الحديث عن الجريمه الحوثيه الجديده في
مختلف منصات التواصل مطالبين بمحاسبه
الحوثيين والمتورطين معهم في سرقه اموال
اليمنيين ما كشفته وثائق الحوالات المعلقه
في صنعاء لا يمثل الا جزءا يسيرا من اعمال
شبكات الفساد التي يديرها الحوثيون وفق
خبراء بعد ان تعمدوا تدمير اقتصادي البلاد
منذ انقلابهم على الدوله عام 2014 من فان
دبيس العربيه عدن